all right so I want to talk with you
about this today I should have done this
a while ago but now that the shows in
danger of being canceled it has to
happen like right now so every couple or
few seasons there's always a really good
show that gets moved to Friday night by
Fox and thus is in danger and getting
canceled this time it happens to be a
show called Fringe now if you haven't
watched fringe I understand why you
haven't watched Fringe because you
probably thought what I thought when I
first heard about friends and it was a
ripoff of the x-files fantastic but it's
really not it's really nothing like the
x-files it's more like a Michael
Crichton book Fringe deals with fringe
science kind of stuff hence the name
fringe you know stuff that sound like
the realm of possibility scientifically
speaking not impossible not quite proven
but theoretically possible that makes
sense
example everything in the world's moving
molecules take a solid like a wall it's
solid because the molecules are moving
very slowly but theoretically speaking
if you speed up the molecules you should
be able to walk through the wall that
it'll just be a goopy mess and in fringe
someone finds a way to walk through
walls but there's an overarching story
that's one of the coolest things I've
seen since like lost a story that might
not be able to conclude because fringe
has been moved where shows go to die as
I've said that is Friday night which
makes no sense because fringe is in his
best season ever it makes no sense to me
to take a show that's in his best season
ever and move it to Friday night where
everything gets canceled and one of the
guys that Fox is one of the higher up
guys that makes these kind of stupid
decisions when fringe was first moved to
Friday night it didn't take too big of a
hit like the first week and he was like
I'll see you make a show right and it
doesn't get affected with him Musa
Friday night so there that is
I think I'm paraphrasing but that's
pretty much what he said which is him
going it was canceled because it was a
dumb show and it was cancelled because
it was a dumb show and now the ratings
are dropping on Fringe because it's
target demographic goes out and does
[ __ ] on Friday nights it's almost like
whoever makes these decisions or just
being childish like - like no I will
keep moving chose - Friday night to
prove that it doesn't always get
cancelled that's like putting a penny
and a light socket and be like no sooner
or later it's not going to shock me even
if by fluke it doesn't happen it doesn't
mean you're right but hey it doesn't
make as much as American Idol so it's
got to go cuz it's all about the money
and the acting and fringe is really
solid
I mean Joshua Jackson's really good in
it the chick who plays Olivia Dunham I
don't know her name cuz she's hot but I
don't know
she's really good in it and John Noble
Denethor from Lord of the Rings plays
this crazy scientist who was like dr.
Frankenstein 20 years ago and he spent
the last 20 years in an insane asylum so
he's a little crazy personally I think
he's robbed for a Golden Globe like
every year and in season 3 everyone's
diversity and acting has to step up a
notch and it's awesome if you watch
fringe here's how it's going to go down
season one's a bit episodic until the
last few episodes probably the last
quarter of the first season then it
starts getting into main story arc
couldn't season two picks up it's a
little episodic also by episodic I mean
like you know freak of the week like oh
here's our case today here's our case
the next day here's our case the next
day you know and Season 2's like that
until about halfway through and then
after that it starts getting into main
story arc season 3 is like all main
story arc and the main story arc is
great I can't tell you too much about
the main story arc I can tell you fringe
is pretty much like this fringe science
on a Michael Crichton level and the
world's going to end because of
something that happened years ago the
world is going to end now and this is a
spoiler issues I'm in a gap I think it's
one of those things that'll intrigue you
enough to watch it so if you don't want
to see this on a plug your ears or
something until I do this alright here
we go it does deal with an alternate
dimension a dimension like ours but it's
different so the characters in one
dimension exist in the other dimension
they're just a little different there
which is why the acting has to get
stepped up a notch all right you're good
yeah unplug yeah you're good so I would
say watch Fringe save this show I do not
want to see Fringe get canceled because
of some dumb ass decision to move it to
Friday night when people know that
that's when shows get cancelled but that
would be unconscionable
so I'm Jeremy and I approve of Fringe I
want to see how the show turns out I
want to enjoy it for about 6 or 7
seasons not too much to ask many people
have tried to duplicate the lost thing
you know the whole supernatural thing
that intrigues people and they have
failed time and time again but fringe is
the closest thing since lost
so watch fringe on Friday nights on Fox
save the show catch up in the last
couple seasons if you need to actors
preferred and if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]